y
[Música]
es de noche este 4 de junio en cali
tercera ciudad más importante de
colombia
los manifestantes lanzan piedras contra
los policías y usan lasers para no
dejarlos ver
[Música]
güímar y que los pasados y paramédicos
ya no levante a la obra
este joven no fue herido por la policía
40 minutos más tarde murió en el puesto
de socorro por las heridas que recibió
se llamaba segundo jaime rosas
esa noche cristian sánchez otro
manifestante también resultó herido por
las fuerzas del orden y también murió en
ese mismo puesto de socorro de hoy es 4
de junio tenemos dos compañeros caídos
por armas de fusil
estos hechos ocurrieron en cali
en el barrio villa del sol las tensiones
han sido pan de cada día en este barrio
desde que comenzó el paro nacional el
pasado 28 de abril las razones del
descontento un proyecto de reforma
tributaria criticado por aumentar los
impuestos a las clases medias y
populares aunque el proyecto fue
retirado el 2 de mayo las
manifestaciones continuaron para
denunciar además la corrupción las
desigualdades y también la violencia
contra los manifestantes por parte de la
policía y de civiles armados es lo que
atestiguan cientos de vídeos aficionados
y nuestros observadores
[Música]
en este puesto de socorro instalado al
inicio de las manifestaciones este
hombre atendió a los heridos esa noche
del 4 de junio pidió mantener el
anonimato por las amenazas que ha
recibido el personal médico
en este punto tuvimos alrededor de 30 a
36 heridos 2 fallecidos por impactos de
arma de fuego
logramos extraer como tal el plomo de la
herida y algo que cataloga de las
heridas de arma de fuego es que el
orificio de entrada es más pequeño que
el orificio de salida
en unos podemos apreciar que fueron con
armas de largo alcance hubo algo que nos
impactó mucho fue que las mismas
autoridades el estado como tal no nos
dejó ingresar las ambulancias para que
los sacaran a ellos cuando en este
momento aquí era un campo de batalla
teníamos que atender pacientes que nos
llegaban tras el suceso tirados en el
pasto y escuchar cómo era que nos rozan
las balas
[Aplausos]
algo aterrador en el lugar otros
indicios permiten suponer que se
utilizaron armas de fuego como estos
impactos de bala en los árboles según un
informe publicado por tres ongs
colombianas 44 personas habrían muerto a
manos de la policía durante los dos
primeros meses de manifestaciones al
menos 33 de ellas por arma de fuego
alejandro rodríguez trabaja para la ong
temblores que ha recopilado vídeos y
testimonios desde el comienzo del paro
tanto en la normativa nacional como la
normativa internacional
reprimir o usar armas de fuego por parte
de la fuerza pública en contextos de
protesta pues no está considerada tras
los hechos ocurridos el 4 de junio en
cali la policía colombiana aseguró haber
iniciado una investigación disciplinaria
[Aplausos]
el 14 de mayo los manifestantes se
congregaron en popayán en el sur de
colombia
sebastián quintero un estudiante de 28
años de edad era uno de ellos que a base
de sebastián
sale el 14 terminó de vender arepas ese
día dijo me voy a la protesta porque el
día anterior había ocurrido lo de la
niña allison allison una adolescente de
17 años fue arrestada al margen de la
manifestación del 12 de mayo y llevada a
la comisaría por el esmad la policía
antimotines al día siguiente la joven se
suicidó
me bajaron el pantalón y me manosearon
hasta el alma dice el último mensaje que
subió a su cuenta de facebook una
investigación está en curso pero la
cólera de los manifestantes no se hizo
esperar en la tarde del 14 de mayo
frente al puesto de policía al que fue
traída la adolescente la atención
estalla
[Música]
sobre esta avenida la manifestación se
torna violenta la policía responde con
el lanzagranadas venom a que significa
veneno en español una nueva arma que se
utiliza en colombia según vídeos de la
misma policía colombiana ven un es un
arma no letal concebida para dispersar a
los manifestantes
con una carga de 30 granadas
lacrimógenas y aturdidoras permite
disparos parabólicos para no causar
heridas
pero vídeos grabados en popayán ese 14
de mayo muestran que algunas granadas
fueron disparadas directamente hacia los
manifestantes incluso contra algunos que
están muy cerca del lanzador
el 2 de junio la justicia ordenó
suspender el uso del veneno en popayán
por su uso directo sobre los
manifestantes ese 14 de mayo la policía
también usó contra los manifestantes la
tanqueta de agua granadas aturdidoras y
vehículos blindados
al final de la tarde en otro vídeo sobre
esta misma avenida se ve una escena
confusa una fuerte detonación luego un
manifestante es evacuado de entre la
multitud es sebastián quintero
según la ong human rights watch la
responsabilidad podría ser del esmad el
smac dispersó una protesta pacífica con
cartuchos de gases lacrimógenos y
aturdidoras según vídeos y otras pruebas
uno le impactó en el cuello
y al parecer no sé
un objeto es lanzado por parte de la
policía de forma que cada pase en globo
para que pase por encima de los escudos
y cause daño a los muchachos
si hay una hay un acto premeditado esa
es una acción deliberada por parte de
quien tiró
se abrió una investigación pero para
finales de junio ninguna fuente oficial
ha entregado elemento alguno sobre las
causas de la muerte de sebastián
quintero
aunque causan menos muertes que las
armas de fuego las llamadas armas no
letales mataron cuatro personas desde el
28 de abril según las ongs e hirieron a
otras 207 lo que vemos es que los
cilindros de gases se están lanzando
directamente a los rostros de los
manifestantes y esto pues tiene un claro
objetivo de generar una discapacidad y
de asimismo de dejar una herida
permanente en el cuerpo de las personas
que si bien no la va a asesinar si le va
a quitar y si le va a dejar una herida
para toda la vida como lo puede ser
perder la visión
los activistas han contabilizado 149
heridas en el rostro 70 de ellas en los
ojos
devuélvanse a su territorio
9 de mayo en cali en este exclusivo
barrio del sur de la ciudad los
habitantes se enfrentan a los
manifestantes indígenas llegados del
cauca un departamento vecino les
reclaman por participar en las protestas
allí mismo un hombre de camisa blanca
dispara en dirección de los
manifestantes indígenas
ese día la misma escena se repite en dos
zonas más de cali
en esta glorieta
y en esta calle
la pistola que usa este hombre en el
vídeo es lo que se conoce en colombia
como un arma traumática dispara balas de
caucho y se supone es no letal un vídeo
grabado en este barrio resulta
particularmente inquietante
un policía parece acompañar a un hombre
de civil que dispara sobre los
manifestantes indígenas a unos pocos
metros de allí ese día se usaron armas
traumáticas no letales pero también
armas letales según los manifestantes
indígenas 12 de ellos resultaron heridos
la lectura que nosotros tenemos de estas
personas de civil de camisas blancas que
están armados es que si la policía
estaba ahí o no puede deducir que eran
civiles que eran policías de civiles
este incidente no es un caso aislado el
28 de mayo en cali hombres de civil
dispararon sobre los manifestantes en un
puente
ahí también había policías a su lado
desafiando
andrés escobar es uno de estos civiles
es un empresario del barrio más tarde
explicó que junto con sus vecinos creó
un grupo para defender según ellos la
propiedad privada y el barrio ante la
violencia de ciertos manifestantes dijo
que disparó con un arma traumática no
letal
los disparos fueron para disuadirlos ya
que estaban avanzando para quemar el
cairo
y bueno la policía japonesa
al mismo tiempo que ocurrían los
disparos a tan sólo un kilómetro de allí
se llevaba a cabo un concierto en apoyo
a la movilización social
álvaro herrera de 25 años es estudiante
y uno de los músicos
pero el concierto terminó antes de
tiempo por razones de seguridad debido a
otro tiroteo en estos hechos también se
vieron implicados hombres de civil
armados y policías
álvaro herrera terminó en medio del
tiroteo cuando trataba de regresar a su
casa yo empiezo a grabar todo el momento
hasta que en un momento dado retroceden
uno de los de los civiles armados pese a
que apunta con su arma y yo en defensa
propia tomó una piedra o entonces llega
otro civil por mi flanco izquierdo me
toma el cuello me somete intención del
carmen
soy arrastrado hasta cierto punto en
donde me he entregado a la policía
nacional álvaro herrera fue llevado a
una estación de policía donde fue
obligado a hacer una declaración falsa y
por qué
[Música]
fue liberado al día siguiente
las circunstancias de su arresto dejan
entrever la existencia de una
complicidad entre los policías y los
hombres de civil armados la policía
investiga este caso una segunda
investigación está en curso para
identificar a los civiles que dispararon
sobre los manifestantes el 28 de mayo
así como a los policías que nada
hicieron para impedirlo
el 6 de junio el presidente de colombia
iván duque anunció que los policías
serán mejor entrenados sobre el uso de
la fuerza y el respeto de los derechos
humanos pero no que se negó a
desmilitarizar la policía ya trasladarla
del ministerio de defensa al del
interior como lo exigen las ongs y los
manifestantes una decisión que podría
mermar la violenta represión
[Música]